what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and there has been a lot going on
recently with Jonathan Majors most of
you probably know that he was arrested a
little bit ago he was arrested March
25th for allegedly strangulation assault
and harassment of his 30 year old
girlfriend however the case wasn't so
clear-cut there was a lot more to this
case than meets the eye as when he was
arrested his lawyer came out and stated
that Jonathan Majors was actually a
victim in this case and was not guilty
of any of that and not too long after
his lawyer released supposed text
messages from his girlfriend stating
that he didn't do any of it and that she
would tell everybody including the judge
the police everyone that he didn't in
fact do it so there is a lot going on
with this case and the case for Jonathan
Majors goes to court May 8th and the
outcome of the Court's decision on May
8th is going to determine a lot of
things for the future of Jonathan Majors
including his future at Marvel Studios
now last that we heard Marvel Studios
contemplating about possibly replacing
Jonathan Majors as king the Conqueror in
the MCU was kind of on hold Insider Jeff
Snyder on the hot mic podcast stated
that he's heard that Marvel hasn't made
any decisions regarding Jonathan Majors
but they've met with or spoken to his
agent to discuss potential options going
forward and as far as we're concerned
right now Marvel Studios is basically
waiting to see what the Court decides on
May 8th or possibly even further down
the line in the future if they don't
come to a decision on May 8th which if
it's pretty complex then more than
likely they won't it'll more than likely
take a few court dates and like I said
if we heard anything else about this
about any further development of the
story we do an update and that's what
we're doing now as we've heard Marvel
Studios might have a certain type of
actor or maybe a specific actor in mind
to potentially replace Jonathan Majors
if all goes bad now unfortunately this
is simply what Marvel Studios has to do
they have to be prepared for everything
they have to be prepared for Jonathan
Majors being innocent and continuing
forward with him and the MCU in which
they're still going to be some backlash
because there are a lot of people out
there that think that he is very much
guilty and even if he's proven innocent
there are still going to be people who
think he's guilty but then of course
they have to be prepared for the
opposite they have to be prepared for
him being found guilty and according to
this new report they are indeed
preparing for it now there's a lot to
talk about about this and we'll get into
it but first let's go over this report
this report is coming from the same
person Jeff Snyder who reported last
time that Marvel Studios had spoken with
the team for Jonathan Majors following
his arrest and on the hot mic podcast he
said this here's one I wanted to talk
about did you see who got cast in that
Brad Pitt racing movie damsem Idris I
think he's from snowfall and so that's
like a big part right that is the young
hot shot racer opposite Brad Pitt in
this one 150 to 200 million dollar
racing movie that was a big deal that he
got that speaking about that part in
that movie and he goes on to say and
again even though there hasn't been any
movement on the Jonathan Majors front
I've heard that's the kind of actor who
like if Jonathan Majors got the Buddhist
King someone like damson Idris is the
type of the person that Marvel may look
to replace him if that in fact happens
so according to Jeff Snyder Marvel
hasn't yet made any official decisions
but they are in fact preparing for
everything which is something that the
studio has to do now this is pretty
controversial right now in a lot of
different ways and we've tried to remain
neutral on the channel here now Jonathan
Majors portrayal as king I do personally
really love I think he does a great job
and I was really really excited to see
him be king in the MCU so the big
question is will Marvel actually replace
him and how much does that just decision
actually depend on the outcome of a
court hearing because it really kind of
depends and we can look at Warner
Brothers for an example on that you can
look at everything that happened with
Johnny Depp he was playing Grindelwald
in the Fantastic Beasts movies then
everything with Amber Heard burst out
there was so much going on with that and
the outcome resulted in Johnny Depp
being fired from Warner Brothers and
fired from the Fantastic Beasts movies
and they replaced him this could be what
Marvel Studios is preparing to do this
exact situation where if Jonathan Majors
is found guilty they replace him however
then we have to look at Ezra Miller he
did a lot of crazy stuff like a lot of
crazy stuff yet he is still the flash
they are still promoting his movie and
Warner Brothers expressed that they were
concerned for their mental health and
were getting them help so two very
different decisions were made for two
very different actors who did two very
different things and in fact I would
state that Ezra Miller probably caused
more problems for the studio than Johnny
Depp accepted now there's obviously a
lot that goes into this decision making
that we don't really get to hear about
and right now as it stands it does look
like Jonathan majors has some proof that
he is innocent and if that is the case
if he is found innocent then Marvel
Studios shouldn't do anything they
should continue with him as king the
Conqueror in the MCU in fact the only
reason that he was arrested is because
it is an actual procedure that the cops
have to do when they arrive on scene
Jonathan Majors attorney stated
unfortunately this incident came about
because this woman was having an
emotional crisis for which she was taken
to a hospital yesterday the NYPD is
required to make an arrest in these
situations and this is the only reason
Mr Majors was arrested we expect these
charges to be dropped soon and like I
mentioned they have also came out
recently and shared screenshots that
this woman sent Jonathan Majors stating
that he was indeed innocent that he
didn't touch her and that she was
willing to tell the court and the police
that exact thing he was innocent and
this is what Jonathan Major's lawyer was
talking about when she said that he was
the victim because he was arrested for
really not doing anything now of course
people are up in arms stating that they
kind of forced her to say that and we
don't know we do know that as soon as
Jonathan Mages was arrested before any
news came out his lawyer did State he
was innocent we'll have to wait and see
what the court says which apparently is
what Marvel Studios is waiting for as
well now there is the possibility that
even if he is found guilty they could
keep him as King this is what Warner
Brothers in DC did with Ezra Miller
however it does seem like Marvel Studios
is preparing to replace him they have to
do that as a precaution they have to
examine every single possibility because
Kang is a huge character in the MCU
right now he's going to be in a lot of
different projects but he is going to be
the main person in the Kang Dynasty and
then again in secret Wars It's all about
him he's the big bad so Marvel has to be
prepared so what would exactly happen if
there replaced him well in a Multiverse
Saga it wouldn't exactly be that hard we
are right now existing in a universe
within the MCU that is obviously not
real life where variants are a thing and
as we've learned from Loki and
Spider-Man no way home Etc variants
don't have to look exactly the same
variants come in all sorts of different
shapes and sizes and sometimes even
species we did see a scroll version of
King in the Ant-Man and the WASP post
credit scene so although I do think
Jonathan Majors acting as Kane the
Conqueror was phenomenal it wouldn't
exactly be that hard to replace him
unfortunately the whole Multiverse and
variants make it pretty easy to explain
why this new king the Conqueror all of a
sudden doesn't look like the ones that
we've dealt with before he who remains
and the King that is in Ant-Man and the
WASP quantumania the only thing that
they would really kind of have to
explain is the Council of Kings we've
already seen the three of them the Kang
Trio so those have been established as
looking like Jonathan Majors essentially
now now you could essentially make them
kind of look similar because of all the
makeup and Prosthetics they were wearing
but of course everybody will still
notice that's not the same actor that we
saw before and if they replace them
that's just kind of something that is
just how it is there's no real way to
get around that but as far as the main
villain of the King Dynasty goes and
Secret Wars he doesn't exactly have to
look like the other variants now I do
hope everything is true I hope that was
a big misunderstanding I hope Jonathan
Majors did nothing to that woman and I
hope she is truly okay and she was
simply going through a hard time and
there was a big misunderstanding and
everything's gonna be okay in the MCU
but we'll have to wait and see what
really happens and we'll have to see
what the Court decides in the meantime
we are curious to hear your thoughts
about this so please leave them in the
comments down below please don't forget
to like the video and subscribe to stay
up to date on the Jonathan Majors case
and of course all things in the MCU you
can always follow us on Instagram and
Twitter as well and as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof
[Music]